hooked on a feelin tired oh yeah we have
a teaser trailer for guardians of the
galaxy - actually it's called a sneak
peek on YouTube again I'm gonna call it
a teaser trailer because it's a teaser
trailer unless we get another video in
like a week that's actually called the
teaser trailer which is a teaser trailer
with blue that are just funny because we
got a trailer for the Assassin's Creed
movie yesterday and I was like all right
let me check it out see if I'm gonna do
a video about it and I've watched it
those like I'm just not excited for it
so I'm not gonna do a video about it any
Assassin's Creed might be good I'm just
saying the track record for video game
movies has not been great thus far and
one fun movie that came out in 1995 does
not negate the river of [ __ ] that has
followed it the definition of insanity
is doing the same thing over and over
and over again and expecting different
results including without limited to
getting excited for video game movies
and then they suck and you get excited
for the next video game movie then it
sucks and I'm not insane I'm just
eccentric so now the public we common
folk who don't sit in line at Hall H
have our first trailer our first sneak
peek of guardians of the galaxy - and
it's a teaser if ever there was one it
shows some blips and clips of things
well hooked on the feeling's playing
granted in those blips and lips it looks
like some [ __ ] goes down eyes are all
screwed seriously and judging by the
fact that abusive stepdad you know
captain fin head dick is walking with
rocket and he's on the poster standing
with them looks like he joins the team
but really this trailer shows you a
blood blood blood blip and then has some
fun dialogue with Drax and star-lord
they're talking about Gomorrah and star
Lords pretty much like all right yeah
yeah I know she's not my type but hey
I'm gonna try then Drax is like you need
to find a woman who's pathetic like you
he's like you want a hug starlets like
no I do not he's like come here and then
the Drax hugs them because when the Drax
wants to bring it in for a man hug you
give that guy his man hug that one
denies the Drax his man hug I started to
honestly add a point wonder about
guardians of the galaxy - it's such a
detached movie from the rest of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe if you like
the guardians of the galaxy don't even
know about the Avengers and that's where
infinity war or whatever they're gonna
call it now is going to come in I
imagine they're all going to team up in
space balls - the search for more money
and
guardians of the galaxy as a testament
as to why I think Marvel is just doing
it right Marvel's like Pixar at this
point because they made for work like
Thor's a God in that world and when he
was introduced I was like there is no
[ __ ] way that's good oh my gosh it
works think guardians of the galaxy it's
like I what is that gonna work oh look
at that it does I hope they have a good
villain this time because we were
kidding Marvel has their flaws or
Achilles heel is their villains they're
just never that interesting but really
quick video for quick thoughts guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 looks to be what
people liked about the first guardians
of the galaxy movie shoved into about a
minute and a half here grand scale
galactic epic battles and humor there
you go so the guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 sneak peek / teaser trailer /
teaser for the teaser who knows what it
actually is have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]